as you can see this is my room
um it is like very similar to your hotel
room i have everything and nothing in
this room actually goes out
for ten days these four walls were all
harun knew
two doors isolated him from the outside
world
every single bottle every single
paracetamol every single iv everything
all the needles everything they use on
me
stays in this room he was rushed to the
royal free hospital in north london with
a high fever
an early symptom of his monkey pox
infection
lesions and scabs in his throat meant
harun couldn't eat or swallow he was fed
through a tube in his arm
it is one of the most extreme cases of
monkey pox ever seen
in the uk
i am by myself alone um
i don't have any family here rather than
my my good couple of good friends i it
was very scary i thought that i'm by
myself i can't do this alone
and not being able to get help from
frontline services was very scary
haroon called the nhs one one helpline
after having a fever of over 39 degrees
for a number of consecutive days
and every single time
i heard the answer that god said call us
when you are getting worse
and i was already diverse i uh checked
my throat and my throat was all white uh
with the with the you know i don't know
pus or um some infection
it got to a stage that i couldn't even
uh swallow my own spirit
monkey pox is not but can present like
an sti sexual health clinics are usually
the first to identify the symptoms
monkey pox cases have trebled across
europe in the past two weeks in the
world health organization is warning
that there can be no room for
complacency vaccinations are being
offered to some communities here in the
uk but the fear is that this rollout
just isn't happening quickly enough but
sexual health clinics are worried about
the procurement and slow rollout of the
vaccine for an epidemic that might last
for months it looks like we are in for
an outbreak that's going to last for the
rest of the year at least before it's
averted what we would like to do is to
be able to have access to more vaccine
more quickly and be able to distribute
it more effectively and all of that
requires resource haroon is finally home
his ordeal is coming to an end but this
global monkey box outbreak is growing
ashish joshi sky news in east london